todo en su apartamento taiwanés es un
recordatorio de sus años de lucha por
Hong Kong
Esta es la bandera que utilizamos
durante 2019 en las protestas contra la
ley de extradición en Hong Kong
2019 fue el año en el kilian y Henry
fueron detenidos por protestar se
convirtieron en figuras mediáticas A
falta de pruebas fueron absueltos pero
su presencia era una molestia para las
autoridades
nos seguía mucha gente gente muy
sospechosa por lo que nos sentíamos
bastante inseguros además amigos que
estaban en la cárcel nos advirtieron que
les estaban preguntando por nosotros
en 2021 decidieron irse a Taiwán un
exilio para protegerse
ahora me siento Solo y Vacío pero Decidí
irme de Hong Kong porque quiero mi
libertad
sus amigos no corrieron con la misma
suerte un amigo cercano a menudo les
enviaba cartas desde su celda en Hong
Kong
en esta carta nos dice que no nos
preocupemos por él y que espera que
vivamos una vida feliz
por eso tenemos que hacer muchas muchas
cosas para compensar para que su
sacrificio valga la pena
seguir luchando por Hong Kong incluso a
700 kilómetros de distancia
aquel día en taipei la pareja organizó
una concentración Para apoyar a los 47
junconeses que fueron encarcelados por
haber intentado organizar elecciones
Taiwán es un muy buen lugar para luchar
contra el partido comunista chino porque
está muy cerca a Sólo una hora en avión
de China y además está bajo la amenaza
diaria del partido comunista chino
Taiwán es uno de los países más
democráticos libres y liberales de Asia
Oriental e incluso de todo el mundo
proximidad geográfica cultural y
libertad de expresión
Taiwán no tardó en abrir sus brazos a
los manifestantes que huían de China
en 2020 más de 10.000 visas fueron
concedidas a junconeses el doble que en
años anteriores pero él no puede
regularizar su situación muchos no
pudieron quedarse
según este abogado los procedimientos
son poco transparentes Taiwán considera
que estos emigrantes de Hong Kong son
emigrantes chinos y teme por su
seguridad nacional
desde el punto de vista taiwanés china
ha sido una amenaza desde hace mucho
tiempo por eso el gobierno tiene más
cuidado con las personas procedentes de
China quiere evitar que en Taiwán haya
personas que cooperen con el gobierno
chino o que reciban dinero chino para
atentar contra el sistema democrático
taiwanés
[Música]
este pastor taiwanés que está en
contacto con ingleses de Hong Kong les
ayuda desde 2019 su iglesia y sus misas
en cantonés rápidamente se convirtieron
en Un refugio para los exiliados
había más de 100 personas reunidas
adentro tenemos espacio para 80 pero no
era suficiente entonces abrimos la
puerta y todos se sentaron aquí
Incluyendo a los niños todos juntos Pero
hoy muchos de ellos se han ido por las
dificultades legales en Taiwán
prefirieron irse a Inglaterra por
ejemplo
por apoyar al pueblo de Hong Kong tanto
material como psicológicamente este
pastor se ha convertido en blanco de
intimidaciones
ya hemos visto gente extraña merodeando
por aquí pero a mí nunca me han seguido
hemos recibido llamadas amenazadoras
pero no estamos preocupados porque la
policía de las agencias gubernamentales
de acá cerca envían patrullas aquí
regularmente
sin embargo la mayoría de los refugiados
junconeses que viven en Taiwán temen por
su seguridad y decidan permanecer en el
anonimato Sí sí
En las noticias queda claro que China
tiene sus conexiones aquí en Taiwán
tiene capacidad de influencia si uno se
muda A Taiwán y expresa su opinión muy
abiertamente no se sabe Tal vez tenga
problemas en el futuro
[Música]
miedo a expresarse incluso lejos de Hong
Kong este artista en el exilio es
testigo de esto a diario
Taiwán Y claro que conocía a otros que
eran también como refugiados políticos
pero a veces sentía que aunque sus
cuerpos estuvieran libres físicamente en
Taiwán a veces sus mentes no lo estaban
del todo hay una presión invisible que
existen las cabezas de todos y el
partido comunista chino es quien la
construye en las Mentes de los exiliados
el arte es un arma cuyo a Taiwán para
luchar contra la autoritarismo chino
basta con ir a cualquier museo verano
obras de arte políticas y esos políticos
esas causas sociales hace tiempo que ya
no existen pero esas obras siguen ahí y
la historia de la lucha del espíritu
humano aún puede leerse y comprenderse
hoy saber eso me dio fuerzas
su próxima batalla es ayudar a mantener
la democracia en Taiwán
[Música]